und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen das sind
schon sehr spezielle Zeiten in denen wir
leben selbst das Objektiv zu klärende
Detail ob jemand im Krankenhaus war oder
nicht geriet heute zum diplomatischen
Zankapfel einfach weil es sich bei
diesem jemand um den russischen
Außenminister handelt wir spüren es ist
nicht einfach wenn sich die Welt trifft
zum G20-Gipfel oder um es mit dem
Bundeskanzler zu sagen das wird noch ein
harter Ritt wie wichtig miteinander
reden aber dort bereits sein kann zeigt
die Tatsache dass sich die beiden
mächtigsten Männer dieser Welt heute zum
ersten Mal getroffen haben seit Joe
Biden US-Präsident ist und von Chinas
Staatspräsident waren dabei interessante
Töne zu hören aus Bali berichtet
annegalinek
der rote Teppich trägt am Tag vor dem
G20-Gipfel auf Bali noch Schonbezug
nicht lange allerdings denn schon am
Nachmittag schreiten auf ihm zwei Männer
zu einer schwierigen Verabredung der
amerikanische und der chinesische
Präsident finden dass sie reden müssen
und zwar schonungslos nach fünf Jahren
zum ersten Mal von Angesicht zu
Angesicht
die Welt ist groß genug für unsere
beiden Länder um uns zu entwickeln und
zu prosperieren solche Ideen Ping laut
chinesischem Transkript gesagt haben die
Präsidenten reden offen über die
gegenseitigen roten Linien das China
weiter aufrüstet und Taiwan bedroht ist
eine für die USA das Amerika mit Zöllen
und exportverboten die Produktion von
Mikrochips behindert eine für China und
das China ungeniert Russland unterstützt
und so die anti-westliche Allianz
verstärkt ist die dickste rote Linie
überhaupt beiden will ausloten wie stark
Chinas Sympathie für putinskrieg noch
ist und entdeckt erste Risse
wir haben über die russische Aggression
gegen die Ukraine gesprochen und waren
uns einig dass die Drohung Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen absolut inakzeptabel ist
ausgerechnet in der Traumkulisse von
Bali wird also ab morgen auf dem Gipfel
der 20 mächtigsten Industrie- und
Schwellenländer der Krieg verhandelt der
indonesische Gastgeber hatte Putin
ausdrücklich eingeladen und wollte das
stetige Thema am liebsten von der
Tagesordnung nehmen um eine Spaltung des
Clubs zu verhindern dagegen aber
sperrten sich die Europäer für mich wäre
es wichtig dass wir nicht drumherum
reden und jetzt geht 20 repräsentieren
einen großen Teil der Weltbevölkerung
einen großen Teil der
Wirtschaftsleistung der Welt und
insofern sind die Verständigung die hier
gelingen und auch die Diskussion und der
Streit notwendig um einen Beitrag dazu
zu leisten dass es besser weitergeht als
es gegenwärtig der Fall ist Putin
entschied selbst nicht zu kommen und
schickt dafür seinen Außenminister den
bärbeißigen Sergej lavrov der nach
seiner Ankunft für Verwirrung sorgte
weil er offenbar auf Bali ins
Krankenhaus musste seine Sprecherin
beeilte sich ein Video des Ministers in
Shorts und T-Shirt zu posten lavrov
nutzte die Gelegenheit sofort um gegen
westliche Journalisten auszuteilen
unten ehrlicher sein öfter mal die
Wahrheit schreiben und nicht immer nur
einseitig berichten wo immer die
Interessen Russlands betroffen sind
für Streit wird mit lawrovs-teilnahme am
gipfeltisch gesorgt sein Traumkulisse
hin oder her
ja bringen wir unsere Korrespondentin
unseren Korrespondenten mit dazu
zunächst zu Elmar thevissen der mit dem
US-Präsidenten unterwegs ist auf Bali
aktuell Elmar was hat Joe Biden aus
US-Sicht heute erreicht
naja zunächst mal dass man sich uneinig
sein kann und darüber ist man sich einig
bei eben den Themen wie Taiwan wie
Menschenrechte und Handelshemmnisse aber
das beide Seiten viel größeres Interesse
daran haben dass es darüber nicht zu
einem neuen Kalten Krieg kommt und
deswegen will man eben doch
zusammenarbeiten es werden
Arbeitsgruppen gegründet auf
kabinettsebene die sich mit Klimakrise
und mit Schuldenkrise und mit
pandemiebekämpfung auseinandersetzen
werden und man hat sich eben auch darauf
verständigt dass man ganz klares Signal
an Moskau sendet keinen Einsatz von
Atomwaffen auch keine Androhung des
Einsatzes von Atomwaffen immer da hast
du es jetzt gerade schon angesprochen
das Zeichen Richtung Moskau eben
möglicherweise offenbar auch aus China
es gibt jetzt Meldungen das Moskau eine
kriegskritik in einer
g20-abschlusserklärung akzeptieren
könnte was ist denn da dran
ja es könnte der Satz hineinkommen in
die Abschlusserklärung der heißt es darf
heutzutage keinen Krieg mehr geben und
als es darum ging bei den Gesprächen das
hören wir aus Diplomatenkreisen da hat
China sich im Grunde genommen nicht an
die Seite Russlands gestellt um diesen
Satz zu verhindern und der Satz ist am
Ende allgemein genug dass auch Russland
zustimmen könnte weil es ist ja immer
noch eine Definitionsfrage ob der
Ukraine Krieg wie wir ihn sehen aus
russischer Sicht ein Krieg ist das
bestreitet Russland ja weiterhin und
deswegen kann es gut sein dass Russland
am Ende zustimmt und es zeigt ein
bisschen dass es einen Graben gibt
zwischen Peking und Moskau also sind wir
gespannt auf die Abschlusserklärung
Wortklauberei oder tatsächlich ein
echter Schritt in eine bestimmte
Richtung gucken wir auf die chinesische
Seite Miriam Steimer ist für uns in
Peking Miriam Bart sich da jetzt so was
wie eine echte Verbesserung in den
Beziehungen zu den USA an oder war das
heute Lächeln für die Kameras
ja zumindest gab es ein Lächeln also
Händeschütteln Schulterklopfen Smalltalk
das war alles heute sehr viel herzlicher
als beim Zusammentreffen von Chi mit
Kanzler Scholz vor zehn Tagen in einem
Punkt sind sich beiden und hier einig
die Beziehungen zwischen ihren Ländern
soll nicht noch schlechter werden
interessant ist wie unterschiedlich sie
von dem Treffen berichten während der
US-Präsident einer Pressekonferenz
abgehalten und Fragen von
Journalistinnen und Journalisten
beantwortet hat haben wir von
chinesischer Seite eine Zusammenfassung
zugeschickt bekommen darin steht nichts
von der gemeinsamen Verurteilung von
Russlands atomdrohungen gegen die
Ukraine von der die US-Seite berichtet
dafür wird die Taiwan Frage als erste
rote Linie definiert die in den
bilateralen Verhältnis nicht
überschritten werden dürfe gemeinsam
dieses Wort kommt in den knapp fünf
Seiten ganze 16 Mal vor konkret gibt es
bei der langen Liste an Streitpunkten
aber keine Annäherung immerhin haben die
beiden versprochen zukünftig in in
einigen Themenfeldern wie zum Beispiel
beim Klima wieder mehr miteinander zu
sprechen was die Eiszeit zwischen China
und den USA angeht haben die beiden
Staatschefs heute zwar noch nicht die
Heizung angeschaltet aber zumindest mal
ein Fenster geschlossen damit nicht noch
mehr kalte Luft reinkommt interessante
Analyse herzlichen Dank nach Peking und
nach Bali
was wer warum auf eine Frage davon gibt
es eine klare Antwort das war ein
furchtbarer Anschlag gestern Mittag
mitten im Zentrum von Istanbul mit sechs
Toten wer und warum auch dazu liefern
die türkischen Behörden heute am Tag
danach Antworten allerdings auch viele
neue Fragen insgesamt 46 Verdächtige
sein in Haft eine Syrerin habe die Bombe
platziert im Auftrag der verbotenen
kurdischen Arbeiterpartei PKK die weist
jegliche Verwicklung zurück es war nicht
der erste Anschlag dieser Art und die
politische Brisanz des ganzen bekommt
wegen einer schnell verhängten
Nachrichtensperre in der Türkei selbst
kaum jemand zu hören oder lesen aus
Istanbul rückwalpot
wenige Stunden nach dem blutigen
Bombenanschlag entstand dieses
Polizeivideo ein Sonderkommando dringt
in eine Wohnung in Istanbul ein
überwältigt eine Frau die mutmaßliche
bombenlegerin wie es heißt gefunden
wurden angeblich auch Munition und
Bargeld ein energisch blickender
Innenminister kommt heute früh zum
Tatort da liegt laut Medienberichten
schon ein Geständnis der
Hauptverdächtigen vor sie habe heißt es
im Auftrag der kurdischen terrormiliz
PKK getötet bzw deren nordsyrische
Ableger ypg
wenn wir sie nicht festgenommen hätten
hätte sie sich nach Griechenland
abgesetzt wir kennen diese
Terrororganisation wir wissen auch wer
sie unterstützt wer mit der
pkk-informationen austauscht das sind
die eigentlich entschuldigen
gemeint sind die USA denen der Minister
eine Mitschuld unterstellt kritische
Nachfragen ob auch andere Täter in Frage
kommen gibt es nicht für Ankara ist die
Sache klar Experten etwas überraschend
auch wenn die türkischen Geheimdienste
sehr gut vernetzt sind und sehr gut
überwachungsarbeit leisten ist es doch
merkwürdig dass man in dieser
Geschwindigkeit nicht nur
Ermittlungsergebnisse präsentiert sich
seiner Sache sicher ist sondern auch ein
politisches narrativ präsentiert was
dieser Anschlag zu bedeuten hat
bekannt hat sich die PKK nicht zu dem
Anschlag im Gegenteil im Netz weist sie
jede Beteiligung zurück ebenso die
kurdenmedizin Nordsyrien Beobachter
sehen viele offene Fragen zum Beispiel
welche nutzen die PKK aus einem solchen
Anschlag ziehen könnte
andererseits müssen wir auch sagen
die was wie die Entscheidungsstrukturen
in diesen Organisationen funktionieren
das können da kann es binnenlogiken
geben die uns vielleicht auch nicht ganz
so zugänglich sind das bedeutet an
diesem Punkt sehr viele Fragezeichen
aber es bleibt einfach sehr viele
Spekulationen
Istanbul war in den letzten Jahren von
Anschlägen verschont geblieben anders
als 2016 wo die Stadt Schauplatz gleich
mehrere Terroranschläge war sowohl der
PKK als auch der Terroristen vom
sogenannten islamischen Staat gerade der
Kurden Konflikt zur fürchten viele
könnte durch die Bombe gestern wieder an
Brutalität zunehmen
wir haben in den letzten Jahren gesehen
dass immer dann wenn Wahlen anstehen und
wenn die politische Konfrontation sich
aufheizt dass dann die kurdische Karte
gespielt wird und dann auch der der
Kurdenkonflikt in der Türkei zu
Eskalation gebracht wird heute wurden in
Istanbul die Opfer des Anschlags
beigesetzt unter ihnen eine 15-jährige
Schülerin die zusammen mit ihrer Mutter
getötet wurde
in Deutschland können wir gerade eine
entscheidende Sozialreform beobachten
auf ihrem Weg durch den
parlamentarischen Gesetzgebungsprozess
und dabei wird klar es ist auch eine
Reform an der sich die Geister ganz
grundsätzlich schalten Hannah ja
allerdings die Union hat wie ange
kündigt Geld im Bundesrat abgelehnt
Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition ist damit
vorerst gestoppt die Union kritisiert
unter anderem dass es bei
Pflichtverletzungen weniger
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten geben soll zudem
lehnt sie die Erhöhung des
Schonvermögens ab einen Kompromiss soll
nun der Vermittlungsausschuss finden den
die Bundesregierung eingesetzt hat das
Bürgergeld soll eigentlich ab dem 1
Januar 2023 Hartz IV ersetzen
die eu-außenministerinnen und Minister
haben neue Sanktionen gegen Iran
verhängt wegen des andauernden brutalen
Vorgehens gegen die Demonstranten im
Land zu den Maßnahmen zählen weitere
Einreiseverbote und das Einfrieren von
Vermögen außerdem beschlossen die
Ministerinnen und Minister den Beginn
einer ausbildungsmission für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte geplant ist
dass zunächst etwas 15.000 ukrainische
Soldaten unter anderem in Deutschland
trainiert werden
die G7 starten haben auf der
Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten einen
globalen Schutzschirm gegen klimarisiken
für arme Länder auf den Weg gebracht
ziel des Vorhabens sei es dass im
Krisenfall schnell Hilfe bereit stehe
sagte entwicklungsministerin Schulze zu
den ersten Empfängerländern gehören
unter anderem Bangladesch Costa Rica und
der Senegal Deutschland sagte 170
Millionen Euro Anschubfinanzierung zu
Deutschland ist im klimaschutzindex der
Organisation Germanwatch zurückgefallen
in dem jährlich erscheinenden Ranking
werden die Klimaschutzbemühungen der 60
größten Verursacher von Treibhausgasen
verglichen unter den ersten zehn Plätzen
sind demnach aus Europa nur die Länder
Dänemark Schweden Estland und Norwegen
Deutschland rutscht auf Platz 16 die
ersten drei Plätze bleiben leer zur
Begründung hieß es kein Land setze sich
genug dafür ein die Erderwärmung auf 1,5
Grad zu begrenzen
Frankreich und Großbritannien haben ein
neues migrationsabkommen geschlossen um
die illegale Einwanderung über den
Ärmelkanal zu verringern gelingen soll
dies durch zusätzliche Sicherheitskräfte
und den verstärkten Einsatz von Drohnen
Hundestaffeln und Hubschraubern zudem
ist geplant dass britische Beamte nach
Frankreich entsandt werden und umgekehrt
in diesem Jahr sollen bereits mehr als
40.000 Menschen illegal über den
Ärmelkanal nach Großbritannien
eingereist sein so viele wie noch nie
der ukrainische Präsident ist ein
Meister der eigenen Außendarstellung das
Bild dass er der Welt und seinem Land
vermitteln will von sich selbst das
kontrolliert er genau auch und gerade im
Krieg so gesehen ist es keine
Überraschung das volumensky heute in
herson war der Großstadt im Süden der
Ukraine aus der Bilder von jubelnden
Einwohnern und gerührten ukrainischen
Soldaten um die Welt gehen seit
Russlands Truppen von dort abgezogen
sind
selensky will die Energie und Emotionen
spüren sagt er heute aber auf die
Menschen in Person warten noch viele
Herausforderungen zeigt daran Hassan
sadi er ist für uns vor Ort
sie haben ihre Stadt zurück sie strömen
seit drei Tagen auf die Straßen von
razon und natürlich auf dem Platz der
Freiheit noch immer schwenken Sie ihre
Fahnen umarmen ukrainische Soldaten auf
die sie so lange gewartet haben
monatelang
schmerzvolle Erinnerungen wechseln mit
zum Himmel jauchzender Freude
ich weiß nicht wie ich mein Glück in
Worte fassen soll und trotzdem ist immer
in mir was diese Orks getan haben
ist noch nicht vollständig entmint und
liegt in Reichweite der russischen
Artillerie die Einschläge sind klar
vernehmbar
und trotzdem ist heute Präsident
selenski gekommen
fast ungläubig lauschen sie ihrer
Nationalhymne Herr sol war die Stadt in
diesem Krieg die am längsten unter
russischer Besatzung stand
das ist der Anfang vom Ende des Krieges
denn man kann sehen wie stark unsere
Armee ist Schritt für Schritt holen wir
uns die besetzten Gebiete zurück
zwei Straßenzüge weiter im Park die
Menschen schildern ihre Probleme es gibt
kein Strom kein Wasser in Version doch
die Polizisten können nur mit tröstenden
Worten helfen
viele Geschäfte sind geschlossen manche
wurden von russischen Soldaten
geplündert wie diese Apotheke
alona verkauft ohne Strom im Dunkeln was
sie noch auf Lager hat es ist nicht mehr
viel
wir sind glücklich weil unsere Soldaten
da sind
wir haben gewartet
so lange
die Kunden kommen jetzt noch weil wir
immer noch etwas im Sortiment haben
wir sind glücklich
und doch wissen die Menschen in reson
dass sie wohl ohne humanitäre Hilfe
nicht auskommen werden die russische
Armee hat die Infrastruktur beim
Verlassen von resson zerstört immerhin
ein behelfsmast für Mobilfunk ist heute
schon wieder in Betrieb
das Leben hat uns hart gemacht gelehrt
wie man überlebt unter solchen
Bedingungen
die Männer von Hessen haben die
russische Besatzung durchgestanden
und wir können unser Gesicht dieser
Bilder vorstellen was sie durchgemacht
haben die Menschen in Person gehen wir
jetzt nach Moskau zu für begasi ist
unsere Korrespondentin dort guten Abend
phobel jedes einzelne dieser Bilder aus
Carson muss ja für Russlands Führung
auch wie eine Schmach wirken bekommen
denn die Menschen in Russland diese
Entwicklung überhaupt mit
ja sie bekommen diese Entwicklung mit
aber unter ganz anderen Vorzeichen das
russische Staatsfernsehen das berichtet
hier über diesen Rückzug aber es nennt
es eine Umgruppierung der russischen
Truppen und es behauptet das sei
geschehen um die Leben der russischen
Soldaten zu schützen auf den
telegram-kanälen vor allem in den
ultra-nationalistischen Kreisen da wird
das Vorgehen des Militärs schon sehr
scharf kritisiert aber diese Jubelbilder
aus der Ukraine die ukrainischen Truppen
in herson die ukrainischen Fahnen in der
Stadt das sieht man hier natürlich nicht
jetzt hatte Russland ja auch die Stadt
hersong gerade erst völkerrechtswidrig
annektiert wie reagiert denn der Kreml
jetzt
der Kreml hat klar gemacht dass er an
dieser Annektion festhalten möchte kann
man Sprecher pestov der hat heute nicht
direkt kommentieren wollen was er davon
hält dass der Lenz gehen war aber er hat
eben nebenbei fallen lassen dass der
ukrainische Präsident sich aus seiner
Sicht dabei auf russischem Gebiet
aufgehalten habe vom wichtigsten Mann im
Kreml ist bisher noch kein einziges Wort
zu dem Rückzug aus herson zu hören
gewesen dabei hatte Wladimir Putin
durchaus öffentliche Auftritte in den
letzten Tagen heute zum Beispiel ein
langes Gespräch mit dem Gouverneur aus
dem altaya-gebiet da haben die dabei
dann über soziale Fragen gesprochen über
Wirtschaft wladimir Putin hat sich als
machad dargestellt als einer der die
Probleme des Landes anpacken will aber
zu dieser zu diesem
Misserfolgen in der Militäroperation die
er selbst angeordnet hat deren
Oberbefehlshaber ist damit möchte er
eben nicht in Verbindung gebracht werden
das ist ein Muster dass wir bei dem
russischen Präsidenten schon in anderen
Krisen gesehen haben aber dass er bei
diesem Thema jetzt so stark auf
Tauchstation geht das ist doch
ungewöhnlich
der Blick aus Russland von für Bega
herzlichen Dank dafür für
und jetzt hier bei uns noch mal Johanna
und
zwar
da Kanzler heute mit einer klaren
Mission zu Gast auf der Asien Pazifik
Konferenz ging es darum neue
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen in der Region
aufzubauen und Valerie Haller dadurch
gleichzeitig Abhängigkeiten abzubauen
von China nämlich ja genauso ist es
Berlin fürchtet enorme wirtschaftliche
Folgen sollte China Taiwan militärisch
angreifen teilweise liegt die
Abhängigkeit bei wichtigen Rohstoffen
bei fast 100 Prozent und für einige
Firmen ist China auch der einzige
Wachstumsmarkt der einzige Markt der
noch profitabel ist Wachstum verspricht
und das Streben nach mir Unabhängigkeit
ist also in erster Linie ein Ziel der
Politik aber ein sehr ausbaufähiges im
Vergleich zu china hält sich der Handel
mit anderen Ländern in Asien noch in
Grenzen der mit Vietnam hatte 2021 einen
Warenwert von 14,5 Milliarden Euro und
der mit Singapur 11,4 andererseits ist
auch China abhängig von Importen und
dabei auch von Investitionen aus Europa
sieht denn die deutsche Wirtschaft bei
den Plänen der Politik überhaupt mit
teils teils china ist für die deutsche
Wirtschaft aktuell nicht komplett zu
ersetzen vor allem nicht für die großen
Konzerne spielen sie dort nicht mit dann
laufen sie Gefahr von der
internationalen Konkurrenz abgehängt zu
werden gleichzeitig will die deutsche
Wirtschaft neue Partner finden auch in
Südostasien die Allianz Asien umfasst
zehn Länder mit nahezu 700 Millionen
Einwohnern und teils satem
Wirtschaftswachstum aber solche Prozesse
gehen über viele Jahre den Länder wie
Vietnam sind selbstbewusst und haben
Erwartungen an ihrer Handelspartner
militärische Kooperation zum Beispiel
also neue Märkte zu erschließen ist
alles andere als ein Selbstläufer vielen
Dank Valerie für deine Einschätzung
nach Juniper hat der Bund nun auch die
frühere gazpromtochter See für
verstaatlicht das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium erklärte
dass dem Gasunternehmen die Insolvenz
drohe was die Versorgungssicherheit
Deutschlands gefährden würde seit April
stand das Unternehmen bereits unter
Treuhandverwaltung der Bundesnetzagentur
die spanische Polizei hat nach eigenen
Angaben in internationaler
Zusammenarbeit eine kriminelle
Organisation im Bereich der
kryptowährungen ausgehoben mit illegalem
Handel sollen die Verdächtigen rund 2,4
Milliarden Euro erbeutet haben allein in
Spanien sollen bereits mehr als 17.000
Kunden betroffen sein zwei Männer seien
in diesem Zusammenhang in Albanien
festgenommen worden
ob Getreide Gemüse oder Fleisch die
Erzeugerpreise für landwirtschaftliche
Produkte sind im September ein weiteres
Mal gestiegen und zwar um mehr als 39
Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
laut dem Statistischen Bundesamt lag das
Plus bei Speisekartoffeln bei
73%. beim Getreide waren es 41 Prozent
und für Milch musste fast 58% mehr
gezahlt werden
der Countdown für die Fußball-WM in
Katar läuft die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft hat sich auf den Weg
Richtung Weltmeisterschaft gemacht die
am kommenden Sonntag beginnen wird erste
Station der Oman dort kam der DFB Tross
am Abend an die Mannschaft von
Bundestrainer Flick wird noch ein
Kurztrainingslager inklusive Testspiel
absolvieren bevor sie am Donnerstag nach
Katar weiter reist
so klingt das jeden Abend
auch heute abend genau 100 Jahre nach
dem ersten Tag auf Sendung
die BBC kann auf eine legendäre
Geschichte zurückschauen und muss
gleichzeitig vor der Zukunft zittern
eine
medieninstitution die es geschafft hat
von allen liebevoll Tantchen genannt zu
werden die nach den Schrecken des
Zweiten Weltkriegs zum Vorbild wurde für
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk auch in
Deutschland für ZDF und ARD die immer
wieder Zeichen setzte das ist London
calling und Trends BBC drei Buchstaben
eine ganze Welt aus Bildung Information
und Unterhaltung eine Welt in der auch
Fehler passierten und passieren und die
jetzt vor dem größten Umbruch ihrer
Geschichte steht aus London Andreas
stammt die ersten Worte der BBC vor 100
Jahren zusammen geschusterte
radioübertragungen ein Studio wie eine
Werkbank
[Musik]
der leyendesingsang der Pioniere auch
dem Alkohol geschuldet
[Musik]
der Auftrag war experimentelle
Unterhaltung zu erschaffen nicht
staatstragend BBC das kam später es war
auf vielen Ebenen Anarchie und vor der
Sendung ging es in die Kneipe
im Zweiten Weltkrieg
wird die BBC zum einen den Band die
Rundfunk Revolution der nachkriegsäre
anführend wird der Sender für die Briten
zu Anti Tantchen Kultstatus
[Applaus]
Unterhaltung Dokumentationen News werden
zu einer weltweiten Marke für die Bürger
von den Bürgern unabhängig von
wirtschaftlichen und politischen
Interessengruppen das
öffentlich-rechtliche gründungsideal das
braucht sich zu entwickeln
den zweiten 50 Jahren wurde die Anstalt
zum echten öffentlichen Dienstleister
bürgernah die Regierung kontrollierend
dazu die Schrulligkeit die
Verschiedenartigkeit das schätzen die
Briten an der BBC
kreative Meisterleistungen weltweite
Anerkennung die auch Skandale nicht
erschüttern können wie einer schlichenes
Interview mit Prinzessin Diana dass der
BBC Journalist nur bekam da er Dokumente
gefälscht hatte andere Fehler sind beste
Comedy eine Namensverwechslung bringt
g-koma ins Studio erst auf dem Weg zum
Job-Interview als Reinigungskraft und
beantwortet tapfer drei Fragen zur
Digitalisierung der Musikindustrie als
Professor g obwohl er für den
Namensvetter ungewollt ein bekommt er
den Putzjob nicht doch die wahre
Herausforderung der Streit mit der
Politik seit 2019 tobt der Kampf
konservative Regierung gegen Tantchen
eine abgehobene städtische Elite sei die
BBC so der Tenor bei den Tories
Höhepunkt der Schlacht exprimiert
Johnsons Idee die Rundfunkgebühr
abzuschaffen ein Abo-Modell einzuführen
es wäre das Ende des
öffentlich-rechtlichen durch die
Hintertür so Kritiker erstmal vom Tisch
bis auf weiteres
sich über Geld oder Programm mit der BBC
anzulegen ist für die Regierung unklug
solange die Briten wie so oft in der
Geschichte mehrheitlich auf der Seite
des Senders sind was gerade wieder er
der Fall ist weil die BBC die jüngsten
Ereignisse etwa den Tod der Queen oder
die politischen Krisen sehr gut
abgebildet hat
die BBC müsste sich verändern kein
leichter Prozess ergänzt pervis doch
heute wie vor 100 Jahren gelte
allgemeine Akzeptanz ist die beste
Lebensversicherung
so ist das wir lernen vor der Sendung
ging es bei der BBC in ein paar bei uns
erst nach der Sendung vom gesamten Team
auch hinter den Kameras danke dass Sie
dabei waren und unser heute schon mal
Update gibt es dann gegen 23 Uhr mit
Christopher Wehrmann
so
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter schauen wir zurück
auf den Oktober global betrachtet war es
einer der drei wärmsten oktobermonate
die es bisher gegeben hat und noch viel
dramatischer sieht es über Europa aus
fast überall rötliche Töne in Frankreich
in Österreich und in der Schweiz waren
ist die wärmsten oktobermonate seit dem
Daten aufgezeichnet werden und genauso
in Deutschland und die erste Hälfte des
Monats diesen Monats war auch sehr sehr
warm und milde Luft erreicht uns noch
einmal aus dem Südwesten aber regnet es
auch mit im Gepäck und vor allem morgen
Abend dann noch mehr von Westen her in
der kommenden Nacht gibt es Regen in den
westlichen Landesteilen das verlagert
sich langsam nach Osten und Norden sonst
gibt es Nebel vor allem nach Osten hin
bei tiefsten Temperaturen von -1 Grad
also hier mit leicht Frost im Südosten
und neun Grad am Niederrhein morgen dann
gibt es erst einmal Regen der sich
weiter Richtung Thüringen verlagert dann
ist es vorübergehend trocken zum
Nachmittag und Abend kommt neuer Regen
von Südwesten her auf im Osten merkt man
kaum da etwas davon da scheint häufig
die Sonne bei höchsten Temperaturen von
15 Grad in Thüringen und auch am
Niederrhein und 9 Grad an den Alpen der
Nacht auf Mittwoch kommt kräftiger Regen
auf der verlagert sich dann ostwärts
weil 7 bis 15 Grad und am Freitag gibt
es die ersten Schneeflocken schönen
Abend